[Music]
i then saw something remarkable
for the first time paul broke free of
our father's instruction
into a rhythm all his own
one of the great scenes in robert
redford's a river runs through it based
on norman mclean's classic novella
fly fishing is one of the most enduring
and enchanting pursuits in the world
during the pandemic it's finding legions
of new followers to explore this
captivating world we traveled to the
birthplace
of american fly fishing to spend time
with a writer who's been on the water
for more than 50 years
and the queen of american fly fishing
who's been at it
for more than 90. pull off a little more
line jeff imagine in this time of chaos
and uncertainty
finding something that takes you away
that puts you back in touch
with the timeless it's why so many
lately have discovered
fly fishing oh strike
nice when you find yourself doing
something and you don't notice the
passage of time
that's what fly fishing does to me just
puts me in like another state peter
kaminski has devoted half a century to
this sport
both casting and writing about it
wherever there's carnivorous fish
someone can catch him with a fly fly
fishing is different than
bait fishing because the fly sits on the
water
it's not food dropped underneath which
can be far more challenging
and rewarding the origins of fly fishing
traced back to the roman empire
but it was the english with old bamboo
rods who really put it on the map in the
1600s
fly fishing started in the u.s in
upstate new york
in the late 19th century
the king of american fly fishing was lee
wolf
who brought it into our living rooms on
popular series like abc's
american sportsman
lee died in a plane crash in 1991
but his wife a master herself is still
going strong at age
94. for me it was being in the out of
doors
the natural world is kind of my church
my religion
joan wolf was first introduced to
fishing in the 1930s
that was almost 90 years ago and you
remember that like
like it was yesterday it determined my
life
basically joan went on to win her first
professional competition at the age of
12
and set many milestones for female
fishers after that
for the past 30 years she's been running
the fly fishing school
that she and her husband founded in the
catskills casting
is your passport to being a good
fisherman
you you've got to be able to cast well
and put the fly
where it should go what do you think
you've come to appreciate or learn
given this extraordinary time in the
sport
for one thing there were very few women
who fished
and so that's been the story of my life
is trying to get
women into the sport and
finally i've had to wait this long they
are now
in joan was gracious enough to give us
a lesson we have a back cast and we have
a forward cast
and so i'm going to do just the forward
cast okay
now with this you see that the rod is
away from my wrist
and i've got a 90 degree angle basically
yeah and i'm going to pull it down in
one piece from the shoulder
just like that do that up and down just
feel what you
know just go up and down and feel the
shoulder
jeff but we're not doing the back cast
okay we're not doing the back casting
you're a hard pupil
thank you for your patience all right it
usually takes a couple days to get the
hang of it
try it again but when done right
there is not much better there is a
seduction
to it very much so when you watch a
shroud feeding
and then you approach it and don't scare
it and then you work on it for a while
and get it to take your fly it's a
dance yeah yeah this fish puts on sudden
bursts of speed
then stops and comes in like a log the
ethos of most american fly fishing has
long been catch and release
eating what you catch tastes great but
done over and over
it's not sustainable for fisheries for
many who spend time in these waters
just being here dancing and chasing
is enough right now more people
there's a craving to to be outdoors you
bet but it's something that people can
always
return to right absolutely and the whole
world has fish fly fishing in it
always in beautiful clean water
love it right you brought me candy i
didn't bring either fish
that's okay what i love what i loved and
i know michelle did
was now somebody else understands what
it's like to try to reel in jeff
trying to teach jeff how to do something
just relax she was cheating
i want to say no to brian applegate
who's our executive producer two things
one
uh my next assignment in the great
outdoors where i learn
something that's also relaxing i'm
always
out pitching that